what's going on guys this is Rob and I
wanted to do a review of guardians of
the galaxy now initially my intention
was to do a video alongside Benny and
Sal well the problem is after the movie
was released after it came out of that
Thursday I had to be up at 5:30 in the
morning on Friday and so I'd assembly
didn't have time to wait up for them and
it would have been ridiculous you know
ridiculously like unfair of me to simply
tell them like put their YouTube
channels on hold so they could wait for
me that'd just be extremely selfish so
they're gonna do review together I
believe and I don't have it uploaded on
the respective channels but since I was
unable to join their thing we're doing a
review separate and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start this review off
with the stuff that you guys want to see
that you guys want to know about I know
you guys want to know about post-credits
stuff I know you guys are curious about
the story about the film but you guys
want to know what's going on I know you
guys want to know post-credit stuff I
know you guys want to know what Marvel's
pointing to with the future of their
Cinematic Universe after guardians of
the galaxy and here's the really
interesting thing this is what I love
the most
the post-credits scene as most of you
guys know gave us Howard the Duck they
said okay Howard the Duck exists in this
universe but that's all anybody focused
on and I think that Marvel did such a
good job doing this what Marvel did and
the post-credits team is they made all
kinds of noise and ruckus over here and
nobody paid attention to what was going
on over there I paid attention to what's
going on over there and I'm sure other
people did too I don't mean to say like
I'm the lone voice of reason in the
world of Marvel Comics Marvel fandom not
at all
but but I paid attention to what was
going on over there and what I saw over
there were a lot of different things so
in the movie we see the collector twice
the first time we see the collector is
when the guardians of the galaxy at that
point in the film they're kind of the
de-facto group but they're kind of a
ragtag they just came together by
circumstance they haven't really like
bonded as a group yet but they go meet
the big collector and the whole reason
is because Peter quill has this ore and
we'll get into that here a little bit in
this discussion but the collector is
going to give them like just a stupid
amount of money for this orb they don't
know what the orb is at that point but
when they enter the collectors domain
and they see all those collections we
see a handful of things and while
like really fast at superfast it's a 20
second scan of everything he has in his
collection and of that 20 seconds I've
actually got it listed right here
I made a post on Reddit listening to
things that I thought that I had seen or
that I know that I saw in the collectors
collections so the first one is of
course Howard the Duck we saw him at the
end of the credits I don't know what the
purposes of having having a Howard the
Duck and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
when we get into our discussion about
Howard the Duck we're gonna learn two
things one Howard the Duck is stupidly
obscure he appears in like two hundred
to something Marvel comics and that's it
and the first like the first few
appearances are like adventure into fear
number nineteen and then like Man Thing
comics and then we get into like you
know his solo run for 30 something
issues and then he just kind of appears
off and on at different comics he's just
really this character that's interesting
but he serves no real purpose and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he has no
powers he has crack foo which is like
you know a martial arts from his NATO's
universe but like he doesn't really
serve much of a purpose so I don't think
there was really any point in Marvel
including him and I don't really think
they even have any intention to do
anything with him but that could be
entirely lying here the next person is
next thing that we see is a Chitauri and
soldier and of course this was simply
just the idea of the Chitauri ins and
the avengers but i'm curious about this
because the collector only really
collects things that are either unique
or are significant and so the Chitauri
ins may be significant at some point in
time I'm not really sure why I'm not
wildly familiar with the two torian's
and Marvel Comics to my knowledge I
think they were created specifically for
the mono cinematic universe but I could
be wrong here but it wouldn't be the
first time that's happened like Agent
Coulson was created specifically for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but he became
so popular that they just folded him
into the comics and brought him into the
ultimate universe and then brought him
into the earth-616 universe I think so I
don't really know what the big deal is
with regards to having digit origins in
there but I think he just might be the
fact that because they invaded the
planet Earth because they were henchmen
of Loki and and Thanos that maybe he
thought they were important and they
need to be
I'm not really sure there's a Dark Elf
which is really kind of interesting of
course we saw the Dark Elves and Thor -
the Dark Elves of course were a very
prominent race in the past they were
very significant in terms of what their
roles were the fact that one of them was
able to possess a the Infinity or I'm
sorry the power Jim without actually
being destroyed in the process which was
the aether from Thor - that's pretty
significant now the one that we see is
not Malekith I think that was his name
that's not the one that said there are
simply just two Dark Elf so I guess
maybe the Dark Elves are inherently
powerful in their ability to all wield
infinity gems I'm not really sure you
hadn't middle of course we don't really
get that explain to us we simply just
see him there and like I said keep in
mind all this is being seen over the
span of twenty seconds or so this next
person is somebody that I'm not sure I
actually saw I think it's him
but I can't swear to it and I think that
person is beta ray bill and here's the
reason why there's a point where we like
span around and we see an individual and
a red cape but is back as to us and we
see what looks like storm breaker or at
the very least like a very powerful like
some kind of a weapon a hammer of sorts
like in the box of with him like it's
just great big huge box like they're all
lined up side by side for the most part
and he kind of looks you know like turns
to the to the side for a second but you
don't get like a full glimpse of them so
I don't really know but something like
that seemed interesting to me because
most everybody else is facing us like we
can see everything this else is in there
but it's like this glaring thing like we
can't see that guy now whether or not is
something that I'm reading too much into
that's entirely possible or whether or
not this could very well be beta ray
bill I don't really know I think a lot
of us sure is kind of you know a lot of
us in the fan base was kind of getting
swept up then this whole element of what
could be in the collectors collections
and what we could actually see later on
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
again you know this is just something
that I think is kind of interesting
um the fourth person I think is probably
the most important element of the the
movie and this is something that I think
no one paid attention to if you guys
remember and Thor - and the post-credits
scene when we see the collector for the
first time there's a great big huge
glass box
and in that box is the cocoon and that
cocoon houses Adam warlock or at least
everybody believes that it does and I
think mom was even said yes that houses
Adam warlock the whole reason we think
that is because that cocoon looks
exactly like the cocoon from the
Fantastic Four when they first
encountered Adam warlock so on so forth
they fought the whatever that group of
scientists were that I can't but they
call themselves anymore but anyway um in
this in the movie at the end and the
post-credits scene the cocoon is hatched
it's destroyed and it's empty now I have
a hard time believing that this you know
Jim the the harnessing of this Jim or
this nfinity Jim that caused the whole
explosion in the first place would
actually cause that would would not kill
all the other members of the guardians
of the galaxy but kill Adam warlock so
my thought is Adam warlock has gone like
he's escaped and he's out in the cosmos
doing his own thing now this I think is
extremely important the reason why is
because during the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline kind of warlock was the one
who was rallying all the troops but you
know course Silver Surfer went to Adam
warlock with him and Gomorrha and pip
his troll were in the soul Jim I'm sorry
in the yeah and soul Jim and he said
look we need your help stuff's getting
really really bad and Adam warlock was
like nope don't care and then had a more
like showed up on the planet Earth with
hip Ingham or they were in disguise and
then he showing up to dr. strange and
says you know like dr. strange and his
crew or something like that but anyway
Adam warlock is the one that rallies all
the earth Brown superheroes that are
available to fight that weren't wiped
out when panelist wiped out half the
life in the universe Adam warlock is
also the one that gathers all of the
cosmic entities so they can all confront
Thanos so Adam warlock is the other side
of the equation you have Thanos himself
more or less versus the entire Marvel
Universe and the entire Marvel Universe
is being led by Adam warlock because of
the fact that this film heavily points
to the fact that we're going to see an
Infinity Gauntlet storyline somewhere
along the line I have a very hard time
believing that Adam warlock will not
play a role in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he's out there somewhere doing
something the cocoon is empty so what in
the world is going on I don't know it
could just be that Marvel says hey the
cocoons empty Adam warlocks out there
doing something but we're just never
going to see or hear from him
I don't really know because in the
comics he only shows up in times of like
huge and massive events so assuming
there isn't anything like the Infinity
Gauntlet the Marvel doesn't that chooses
not to go that direction but we may not
see at a Morlock but I think I think
they will um
the next thing is that we have three of
them three of the six infinity gems that
have been established to us in terms of
the fact that they exist I don't know
exactly which ones like I know there's
the power gym there's the space gym and
I believe there's the mind gym the mind
gym I think was the one that Loki was
using to control the minds of people and
the Avengers the space gym of course I
think was the one that was in this one
and the power gym of course was the
ether from Thor - I could be wrong about
this one being the space gym the one in
infinity I'm sorry and guardians of the
galaxy but I'm pretty sure it is but
nonetheless we have three of the six
infinity gems and we know where they are
we know that Heimdall has one of the
infinity gems he has the the oh god what
is the tesseract and of course Kevin
phage phage or Fang I'm not sure how to
pronounce his last name he's the one
that came out and said yes the tesseract
is one of the infinity gems the other
infinity gem is being held by the
collector himself he has it as the
aether he has the power Jim and the last
one is in possession of a possession by
the xandarians they have they took the
gem that was given to us and guardians
of the galaxy and they've housed it on
Xandar the next thing is the quantum
bands now this is a big deal
the quantum bands was something that if
you really weren't like specifically
look for our units that like you didn't
happen to just like see it then you were
gonna miss it entirely and that's not
was for me like I was looking at so many
different things I was trying to spot
everything that was in there that I was
like oh my god is a quantum bands and a
quantum bands were on this little glass
box and they were sitting on what looked
like a bookshelf or some kind of a shelf
or something like that and there were
stuff that was like stored everywhere it
wasn't like sloppily stored were stored
neatly for the most part but nonetheless
the quantum bands of course are the
bands that are worn by the individual
that is endowed with the power of quasar
the first quasar I think was Wendell
Vaughn now whether or not we're actually
gonna see Wendell Vaughn I'm not really
sure
we might see like file a bell I'm not
sure what direction they're gonna go
with with quasar and if you guys want me
to do a video on quasar we'll do one
later on down the line but the fact that
we see the crimson ban or the the
quantum bands means one of two things
either Marvel simply just again giving
Institute the Hat and saying yes quasar
II it does exist has existed or will
exist in this universe but we'll just
never see or hear from that individual
or that someone somewhere is going to
come into possession of these quantum
bands and they are going to be quasar
later on down the road we don't really
know the last one was really more fun
than anything else
it was Cosmo and Cosmo is the de facto
leader or the head of security I think
for elsewhere for nowhere which is of
course the giant celestial head of the
floats in space and he's a telepathic
and telekinetic dog he was actually the
Russian dog I think that was shot into
space by the cosmonauts I remember who
it wasn't shot him into space but
nonetheless um that was just fun that
was just cool you know to see to see
Cosmo so that's that's pretty much it in
terms of the things that I either
believe I saw or that I know that I saw
and again I think this is mother simply
just setting the stage and saying much
bigger things are going to happen later
on now on to the characters the great
thing about the characters is that I
don't think we got a whole lot of
backstory with them we got some basic
explanation especially like with pure
quill but Peter cross story's a little
bit different in the movie than it is in
the comics in the comics his mom was
killed by the pad hoon and his dad was
an alien that took off and left his gun
for Peter quill in the movie it's not
like that and the movie Peter Quill's
mom dies of cancer and his dad is just
kind of there but almost immediately
after his mom dies his dad's like go
stand outside Peter quill freaks out
runs off and he's abducted by aliens
which of course turns out to be I think
the Kree and what the Ravagers which are
basically like they're looters or
plunderers and they take them along and
they raise him over the next 26 years
and so on and so forth like that's
literally where we pick up with the film
like we see him abducted and then it's
26 years later um they tell us that
Gamora and nebula are sisters and they
are the daughters of Thanos now they're
not directly like the genetic offspring
of
they're simply just like adopted
daughters either by conquest here by
kidnapping of Thanos Robin the accuser
is really interesting here Rana the
accuser is actually a villain he's not
somebody just a guy that's being given
orders he is fighting on behalf of
Thanos and his mecha nations here and
all honesty I didn't really care for the
way they did Ron in the accuser not
necessarily because he wasn't like he
was in the comics but because I think
his character could have been so much
more like in the end like he's not
necessarily a henchman but his motives
are very short-sighted in this film
what's gone on here is that the Kree
have formed a treaty with these
Andorians but Ron the accuser isn't like
this element and the reason why is
because Ronnie the accuser feels like
it's dealing away with the old ways
dealing away with the the I guess the
historical traditions of the Kree
society and so he wants to effectively
like destroys and are and in the treaty
and basically like take the creek back
to the way things used to be we don't
see the Supreme intelligence
anyway on here so maybe the supreme
intelligence doesn't exist maybe the
supreme intelligence was the hidden hand
behind Ron the accuser doing what he was
supposed to do but the way Ron in the
accuser is given to us at pretty much
points to the fact that he's doing this
of his own accord but for the most part
he's kind of a hokey villain and the
oddest didn't really like him too much
you know it was just it was like you
know I mean this is a guy that plays a
very important role in Marvel Comics
with regards to the Kree like he is the
absolute authority when it comes to
enforcing the law of the Kree Empire he
simply just does the bidding of the
supreme intelligence and he's kind of
you know I guess sometimes Knight he
kind of came off like a henchman
you know he is helping Thanos acquire
this orb because if he acquires the orb
for Thanos Thanos will destroy the
Zander
now we get to see Thanos we get to see
him once and it's full like person the
second time after that it's actually
like an image on the screen but Thanos
looks amazing like he looks so awesome
he looks and sounds exactly the way that
I hope he would where he had like this
really deep voice you like arms those
you know kind of kind of thing it was
just a really deep and throaty and huge
voice and I really really really liked
that I was I was afraid of two things
the first thing I was afraid of was when
they said that they were casting Josh
Brolin to play the road role of Thanos
that they were going to make Thanos look
the way he did when he first appeared
and Jim starlet's introduction of Thanos
and tire man issue number whatever was
they didn't do that but here's the
problem with with Thanos and the scene
Thanos is not given size in proportion
to anything else we simply just see fan
of sitting in a chair so we don't really
know how big the nose is like we see
crowning the accuser talking to him
Thanos is in a chair hovering up there
in front of them or the two are standing
side by side so thatís could very well
be really I guess about the size of
Rhonda the accuser he could be six foot
something and you know every bit of 300
some odd pounds and just really really
dense thing could be the same size as
Jack she's a destroyer or he could be 10
feet tall and a thousand pounds and just
like this Goliath of a monster you know
just as big as Hulk is you know we have
no no idea because we don't have any
scale to refer that to of course I think
we're gonna see that expanded later on
we're gonna definitely gonna see it and
I think we'll see some more appearances
I think is what Marvel said of course
we'll see him more in guardians of the
galaxy - I think because the movie takes
place out in space and the cosmos and
whatnot does Andorians alright so we're
given the nova corps john c reilly was a
really great character in the movie but
the one thing that i was really
disappointed in is the fact that there
was no nova force that they just simply
didn't have it and now whether or not
it's because they chose not to use it or
because it simply just didn't exist but
I'm gonna take a breath and bake first I
hit her
that's good stuff um but whether or not
it simply just doesn't exist or they
just chose not to use it is something
that we don't know there's no mention of
it at all like no discussion no nothing
no hint of anything of the NOAA force
being in existence and if you guys
recall our discussion about the Nova
force about Richard Ryder and the Nova
Corps we talked about how depending on
what level you were in the Nova Corps
you were able to manipulate different
facets or a different portion of the
Nova force and the higher of a rank you
were the more of it you can manipulate
and if you were if you were NOAA prime
if you were the top member of the Nova
Corps you can manipulate all of the no
before so you can do pretty much
anything with it
Glenn Close didn't have any of that and
in all honesty I think this was a smart
move on behalf of Marvel here's the
reason why
Glenn Close plays a really good
character when it comes to dialogue and
character development despite the fact
that she didn't have massive roles in
this film she was really more of a
decision-maker more of a leader and kind
of a person saying oh my god everything
he's about to go really bad we knew off
the bat that she was one a very serious
person - she was the highest ranking
member when it came to the Nova Corps
three she was no-nonsense and I liked
this element of her character but at the
end of the day you know I really
couldn't see Glenn Close flying around
and shooting energy blasts it's stuff it
really would have looked looked hokey
and stupid and I'm glad Marvel chose not
to do this I'm hoping they fixed this by
saying that they just simply didn't tap
into the Nova force maybe they don't
know how to wield the Nova force
effectively and maybe there's something
going on they couldn't use it I don't
know the case maybe but I'm hoping mama
finds a way to explain this that we do
see the Nova force and that we do at
some point see Richard Rider now there
was nothing regarding Richard Rider in
this film so those of you guys that have
seen or have how believe that you've
seen some kind of confirmation that
Richard Rider is going to be discussed
or going to be mentioned or have a cameo
of some kind that's not the case that's
never gonna happen not in this film he's
just simply not there of course that
makes sense because this film takes
place on on Xandar and of course and/or
hasn't been destroyed at this point now
again the Marvel Cinematic Universe
takes place in a totally different
universe than the comic books so we may
never see Richard Ryder in this in these
films we may never see him and our may
never be destroyed you know it all just
kind of depends on on what's going on
now when it comes to Drax the destroyer
Drax the destroyer was probably one of
my favorite characters in the whole
movie I was hesitant when they said Dave
Bautista was gonna be playing Drax to
destroyer I was like I mean I don't know
about this I mean you know David he's a
wrestler not an actor he was awesome one
of the coolest things is they were
talking about Drax a destroyer and how
he takes everything literally but here's
the problem that I had that referred to
his people take everything literally and
of course there's one point where Peter
quill says something like like you know
that he made some comments that it went
over everybody's head I'm sorry he said
this is gonna go over everybody's head
you actually destroyer was like nothing
goes over my head like my reactions or
my reactions is too fast or something
like that but it was it was kind of
funny but when I was kind of hoping for
here is that they would touch on the
fact that Drax the destroyer was a
person at one point in time that he was
a human being but this is the cool thing
we never get any explanation on the back
story of Drax a destroyer except the
fact that his wife and daughter were
killed by Rana the accuser and that's it
we get nothing else there's no
explanation on Rana me accuser on the
accuser just shows up he's just there
like he's in a prison when everybody
gets captured when gomorrah and and raka
vicuna and Groot and peter quill all get
captured on sandbar and they're taken to
the zen darian prison like he's just
there like he's the big tough guy and
the prison and of course he ends up
helping them out which leads us into
Rocket Raccoon and Groot
Rocket Raccoon steals the show and I
think everybody expected him to I don't
think there was anybody that went into
this movie thinking that rocky racoon
was going to be lackluster but he was
the great thing about his character he
wasn't overpowering it wasn't as though
it was Rocket Raccoon and the guardians
of the galaxy he had great lines he had
great dialogue but he fit in with
everybody else and he was just as funny
and interesting as everybody else and
that's what I thought was so great about
this movie the character development and
of picking up with these individuals
knowing virtually nothing about them and
seeing the progress with the movie was
fantastic the fact that all we knew
about Peter quill was that his mom died
of cancer and his dad was an alien which
we actually didn't figure out until much
later on to like the end of the movie
you know we don't you know we see his
character evolve and grow and like we
care about his character we want to see
him succeed that he's this guy that is
kind of thrust into these circumstances
that he just can't control that he's so
far beyond his head you know he's he's
so far underwater here you know the
circumstances are so far beyond his head
that he just can't really help but do
the right thing you know Rocket Raccoon
and Groot of course are already together
they're really already that kind of they
have the relationship going in terms of
you know rocket racoon can of course
speak for Greer whenever guru says I am
Groot and that's really all he ever says
that's one of the cool things that I
liked about the film is they stuck with
that when he said I am Groot but he
actually changed it later on in the
movie and said we are Groot which of
course isn't that big of a difference
but I loved I loved the way his
character was done and that's that's
what I was hoping for with when you have
a character like I am GRU the question
that I was wondering is how is he going
to fit into the movie if all he does is
say I am GRU that's gonna get really
boring really fast but what was really
interesting is he would say with
inflections somebody would ask him a
question he would just kind of pause for
a second and say my group and Rocket
Raccoon would answer for him and it was
really really cool it was really good
because even if all you understand even
though you heard was him saying I am
Groot you understood what it was it he
meant and that's what I thought was
really cool about his character good
more was a bit of a letdown to be honest
now as though a doubt is how Donna
played the role perfect because zoe
saldana it's my home girl but um she
played it well I think the writers have
really kind of did a letdown with Gamora
Gamora is an incredibly strong female
character in the comics she is the
premier assassin but in this one she's
just like a sister with a grudge she's
like a chick with a grudge like well I
don't want to see one in the accuser
destroy life so we're gonna we're gonna
portray him and it's like okay look you
know that's that's silly you know she
needed to be cut rope I mean cutthroat
cruel willing to do anything
get the job done there were several
instances when I was watching this film
and I was thinking she would have killed
Peter quill on the spot like she
wouldn't even asked any questions she
was just killed him right there and been
done with it especially when they first
meet each other and Peter quill has the
orb that she's trying to capture like
she would have just ran him through with
a sword that would have been hit and she
was just taken it and walked away
but um over the course of the film as I
saw this element of them effectively
like taming down her character and I
also started to like her character a lot
more she became more relatable in the
sense that you know she if anything she
actually seemed very human and the way
that she acted the way that she talked
which again I'm not you know I like that
element but I'm not really sure how I
feel about it because I felt like the
great potential of guardians of the
galaxy and I think what it successfully
did is show us that there's all this
stuff going on in the Marvel Universe
that up to this point we've seen Iron
Man and Captain America and Thor we've
seen earthbound events things that for
the most part in comparison to what's
going on in the guardians of the galaxy
don't really matter like you liked when
I was watching the movie I was thinking
about like this scale of things that are
going on I mean of course they showed us
Celestials but when one of the
Celestials had the the Jim in question
and it annihilated all life on this
planet you know you see like all these
different things going on all these
different things happening in the mists
light like really like we're worried
about Captain America and shield on the
planet Earth and that's what I thought
the movie did a great job of the movie
gave us scale the movie gave us an
expansion of the Marvel Universe and
showed us that there's so much happening
but there's so much that has the
potential to happen and again the movie
just picks up I mean the movie it goes
from zero to 60 like that I can't really
there we go it goes from zero to 60 like
that and despite the fact that we're not
giving a whole lot of backstory on the
characters it's extremely well done it
is an incredibly exciting and fun and
fantastic film and I think that's what
Marvel was going for
I think Marvel simply just wanted to say
hey guys there's a lot of stuff going on
here and we're just gonna pick up with
it and see what happens and because of
the fact that this film's been so well
received I think that in garden is the
galaxy to you we're gonna get more
explanation we're going to
maybe the Jackson Astoria was a person I
don't know if we're gonna get into the
in-betweener and I don't know if we're
gonna get into the Titans or anything
like that but I think that we're gonna
get maybe some pointing to the fact that
that reaction destroyer was a human at
some point in time and it is of course
in reserve of force now the cool thing
here that I thought was interesting was
after the defeat of Rana the accuser he
says like his job now is to hunt Thanos
which I was really glad to see because
if you guys recall our discussion about
Thanos we talked about how wrong the
accuser was created for the sole purpose
of hunting down Thanos that's the only
reason he exists that he always knows
where Thanos is in the cosmos and his
goal is to always kill thanos every
chance that he gets and so the fact that
they've basically like turned his
character into that now that his goal
his one drive is to hunt down Thanos and
destroy him I think was really cool I
think was really interesting um over the
course of the film we get to see various
races of course we see the Kree we don't
see any Scrolls which I don't really
expect us to at least not that I saw we
didn't see you schools overall because I
think we're kind of running we're
running on about 30 minutes on this I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap this review up
but overall the film was amazing the
film was absolutely fantastic it was
exactly what I hope it had been all the
Marvel films for the most part that
we've seen up to this point have been
getting progressively darker Iron Man
one was really upbeat and exciting and
it was fun but as Iron Man 2 came along
and then Iron Man 3 came along they got
progressively darker - Captain America
the First Avenger started out kind of
dark and then it got even darker with
Captain America the Winter Soldier
The Avengers dealt with an invasion and
the Marvel events the Marvel films that
we see coming out of injures - the age
of Ultron look to the future movies
after that we're not really sure how
hand man's gonna turn out the movie
seemed to be getting more and more
progressively dark but this was just a
fun exciting interesting upbeat movie if
you are somebody that has never read
guardians of the galaxy if you know
nothing about guardians of the galaxy
you can go into this movie and love it
you're not gonna be confused you're just
gonna be like okay I mean I can I can
understand that as things go along they
give you what you need to know as you
need to know it to kind of quote a
phrase that my boss
that told me once that's basically what
they do and that is one of the things
that I think is so great about this
movie it was designed for both us
individuals who love comics and it gave
us the colleges that we want to see they
gave us the tip of the hatch that we
wanted to see but it was also designed
for people that know nothing about comic
books so you can go in sit down eat some
popcorn throw back some coke and have a
ton of your life watching this
incredibly fun and interesting movie so
with that being said we're at 28 minutes
so I want to bring this to an end um
again last thing I'm gonna mention here
this movie points fingers all over the
place and says there's gonna be a lot
coming later on down the line when it
comes to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that this movie is the tip of the
iceberg and the things that we've seen
in all the Marvel films so far for the
dark world for one Iron Man Captain
America Avengers all I kind of stuff
those pale in comparison to everything
the probably going to be happening later
on down one so with that being said I'm
gonna bring this video to an end I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]